good afternoon everybody welcome I'm
mark Cargill I'm chairing this meeting
Tony Jefferson Census apologies he's
unfortunately gone down with a rather
nasty virus so I hope you recovers as
quickly as possible all right thank you
very much indeed everybody right we have
no public speaking Pig public speakers
down today so I'm going to go straight
into the agenda if I may apologies for
absence no no thank you disclosures of
interest members over any disclosure of
interest
count AHA mr. Chairman I would just like
with regard to item 11 World War Manford
airfield compulsory acquisition of third
parties I would just like to say that
that I have been associated with the
airfield over many years and I think
it's appropriate that I don't take
Parker part in the debate Thank You
captain
thank you on the same item I think we've
all had the same letter
so just to note that we've all had that
yes thank you counsel that's right any
other declarations okay thank you
right minutes of meeting members are you
happy with the minutes of meeting and
can I sign them in absence here for
counselor diffident
thank you thank you very much everybody
right now let's move on to the next item
then which is item for motion of motion
rural and urban capital improvements
grants page 17 right okay on this
particular point whose item another
motion are submitted I'm aware that
there are other councils running such
schemes successfully needless to say
there are many questions that need to be
answered before we could adopt a scheme
in in the English county right I
understand also that was a similar
scheme that took place in this council
some years ago but was withdrawn so I
think we need to look into my
recommendation is as per option fee
which is to defer consideration of the
motion to wait report some officers to
the next available meeting of the
cabinet now on this I would expect the
number of questions to be raised such as
a sustainability of the funding for
example I wouldn't want to see reserves
who can apply how the maximum grant
available qualified crime qualifying
criteria are much more and also of
course there will be some administration
included in this as well so I'd like all
the points to be brought into the report
I am aware as I said that accounts the
Richards who brought this forward has
already indicated that there's some
documentation which he'd like to submit
for this review and also to be included
in the in the process as well so I'm
more than happy for that members any
questions capsule pemberton yeah just
some clarification there I think the
question of its roof
an officer's report so in the ordinary
course of events the offer that I just
wanted some clarification about the
involvement of any members which that
that seems to then have the flavor of
some kind of working group where
actually I think the recommendations
talking about a report so I'm just
looking for some guidance as to the
format of the return response and the
process to achieve that so that's would
be health hi yes so what we're thinking
of here is that we would have an officer
lead on this piece of work I know that
councilor Richard was keen to feed in
some of his thinking behind the motion
rather than it be a working group it was
just a feed in any other decision today
well in that case then like to go to the
motion which is to be to defer the
consideration of the motion to it
reports from the officers to the next
available meeting of the cabinet that
will be post elections okay all those in
favor thank you the next item take us
out of here first
apparently there is a cabinet meeting
prior to the elections I'm not
suggesting it be brought forward at that
point it would be after the elections
okay the next item on the agenda is item
5 the first proposed performance
management framework measures and Monica
arrangement 2019 2020 okay second all
right and we've all obviously seen
multiple reports of these over the years
what I would like to say is that this
could well be the last report in this
format because I've indicated this
previously that I'd like to fully review
the structure the content the style of
the report in the new council year again
this is going to be something for the
new counselors as well new members
should have the opportunity to comment
as well I have a number of thoughts of
course I would but I would like to see
each departmental head assess their KPIs
to see if they're still relevant to then
meet the needs and aspirations of this
council do we need as many as that are
there or other too few it's quite a
wide-ranging review should we also move
to a more efficient method of
presentation this is a question for
example certain indicators could be by
exception reporting as opposed to having
the percentage each time and also like
to see updates on some of the
trajectories because one of the items in
the report has been commented on are we
above or below the trajectory it's very
difficult with a snapshot report to
actually see the trajectory over the
year are we going to achieve the desired
result at the end of the the period the
plan pound period so these are sort of
things I'd like to
right I again expect to bring the
strategy to cabins in the new council
year the Appropriations are in the
agenda are there any comments members
councillor Morse
Thank You Jimmy there are the number
right Jim is starting on page 24 CSE one
talks about the BD UK problem program
Jim I don't know if you intended to take
this anywhere else BD UK have you got it
that erosion business if not I'll leave
it to them have you got it down for
urgent business if so I'll leave BT UK
until then you haven't known a great
change and I'm sure the residents regard
the problems as urgent but I accept the
point can I just comment on this
geminate at the moment to pick at your
point it is an urgent problem and but
there is a process and as I as you're no
doubt aware we are actually going
through that due process is emoni and
mr. castle mr. price would you got to it
learnt update on that would make
appointment thank you John
we're talking here about contributing to
phase three of the BT UK program rolling
out broadband in the district we seem to
be hitting problems chairman phase two
is apparently six months behind phase
three which we're talking about here
commencing April 2019 was meant to start
in December so we appear to be five
months behind minimum on that the the
project as you're aware is Coventry
Solihull and Warwickshire but I
understand know that Coventry have we've
drawn from the be the UK scheme and
contracting with somebody else where do
you under Phase three chairman next year
to pay half a million pounds for this
team but I just wondered if this is a
realistic program that we're laying down
here
or whether we should be considering what
we should be doing thank you well I can
I can confirm that Peter is correct that
Coventry have pulled out of the BD you
contract and they are contracting with
City fiber yes that there are delays
with the project I had a meeting with
them last week they are currently in the
process of identifying what impact
commentaries withdrawl has for the rest
of us and it may well be that there's
going to be some more funding coming
back into the remaining districts at the
minute they're still trying to work
through that they've called another
meeting for the 27th of March when the
new numbers in terms of properties for
connection will be released and at that
point they'll have a much better idea
about where they're going with the plan
the current rollout is six months behind
that subsidy right that was advertised
widely across on the on the stakeholder
latest circulation list so yes there is
a significant amount of work still
outstanding on that project but they are
now trying to regroup and by the end of
March we'll have a further plan that
will come forward with and that may be
or so that we will have extra money so
it all needs to be held over until that
meeting on the 27th okay thank you
next point I have five points just to
reassure your chairman I'm not going on
every single one on page 27 we talked
about the capital's council's capital
and investment strategy will be
considered in February 2 9 2019 I know
missed this David's noting that I have
missed this has this been published
chairman Zhu yes publish numbers present
approved as part of the cap councils
considerations at the end
it's in that case I'll move rapidly on
28 champ age 28 on SIL first funds to be
collected allocated by 2 September 2019
I was somewhat concerned by the comment
from the bag at the very end of your
papers German from page 168 the
strategic policy advisor group which
says in light of the current uncertainty
around the timing of reforms the members
agreed that further information was
needed including consideration as to
whether SIL spending arrangement should
be put on hold in 2019 now chairing that
will come as a great concern I'm sure to
many parish councils who have put
through neighborhood plans with a view
to maximizing the SIL they were to get I
wondered if you have an update chairman
on what is actually planned to happen
there if I can assist that there was no
suggestion that Perisher Town Council's
would be would be prevented from
accessing any of their sylvans it was
simply that that the amount of money
that the council's holding as a result
of SIL currently is in the region of
75,000 pounds which if it were to be
divided between schemes of an
infrastructure size perhaps wouldn't
necessarily give the benefit that I
think the council would want to make
with an investment decision so unless we
get a rapid increase in the SIL receipts
received between now and September it
might be a decision for the council to
make at that point but there's certainly
no negative implications for any parish
retain counsel they all still receive
their SIL allocations accordingly thank
you are part of the SIL regime is that a
certain amount goes directly to the
Pasha's I assume that that's gone
straightened yep so they have had some
of the monies it's just that what's in
the
the pot thank you thank you at page 29
and another one for mr. Platts I'm
afraid land charge searches percentage
turned around within 10 working days I
share your reservations about this
report chairman because we've got here
in mid-year 2018 19 result 9.2 8% with a
target now of 50 percent chairman is
this realistic I understand that at the
moment and last month we were running 34
days 34 working days as the average as
the average for completion of land
charge searches much longer than the
period on which most solicitors work
from exchange to completion chairman so
is this a realistic target counsel
Pemberton did you want to comment on
them Phil is the lead officer rather
than mr. Platts answer initially I've
got some updated info from this morning
if needs be yeah so to answer your
question directly councillor Morse but
at the present time as you know the
lunch our service is going through a
huge project to modernize the service
and at this point in time we are in the
middle of phase two so phase one was the
purchase of the new software to answer
the lunch heart searches Phase two is
the start of populating the system and
phase three is going to be the cleansing
of the data to make sure that all the
research results are accurate as I say
it's a huge project right at the moment
it is really really difficult to say
whether the target is realistic or
unrealistic the land charge team itself
which comprises three people is face
firstly with clearing the backlog of
outstanding searches but also at the
same time assisting with the project to
move us forward
so to answer your question it's very
difficult to say at the moment but
certainly by the time that we get into
May the prospectus that the data
cleansing will have started and we'll be
in a position where some of the answers
to the questions in the forum will be
will be guaranteed correct so the team
don't have to look at those and as we
move forward in time the amount of
automated answering will gradually
increase because of Internet thank you
I'm going to be more positive in the
sense of I've had the benefit of seeing
the numbers this morning there's a grand
total of 84 searches outstanding across
the piece including the ones that
arrived on Friday and in November that
was north of 350 so there were nine left
in November November and December we'll
be clear before the end of the month and
looking at the numbers there'll be a
handful left in January this 9.2 I use a
look backwards if we were to actually do
the analysis today it would be higher
than that the 34 days is the external
reporting from central government on our
performance I'm quite confident than
when we get to look at the revised or
singing or dancing format that the
deputy leader in envisages that the the
proposed 1920 target it's quite right as
for Grafton says that we haven't moved
this because it's in its it is in a
state of flux because what we would end
up doing is the the targets would be
moving every every time this report was
was actually updated for cabinet so it's
right for us to reconsider in Knight you
know the 1920 target when we come to
review the performance but I just want
to give a really big positive message
that the officers in that team I bleed
by Diane keen are absolutely going a
storm at this at that piece of work and
the the the the positive messages are
coming back and the land charges
companies are
are actually recognizing that the the
turnaround times are falling
dramatically so absolutely want to get
that message out that this that team is
going in absolutely the right direction
final point if I'm a chairman on page
thirty one percentage of disabled
facilities grant application process
with the average entering time of two
forty four calendar days
chairman were currently or last year we
were 163 days we're now talking about a
target of two hundred and ten calendar
days showing that seven months and I
would suggest that for many disabled
people from start to completion of a
project of seven months is unacceptable
chairman I take counsel morsi's point
but but for some disabled people a delay
of a day would be unacceptable and this
is this is now as you know run on a
countywide basis this this scheme and
even at two hundred and ten calendar
days which which is I accept an increase
from from the average of the previous
year it is still significantly better
than the arrangements we had in place
when we operated as an individual
Authority and they're out there are
forecast a number of changes to the
process that are going to be implemented
during the next 12 months which is why
we've had to recognize that that may
well impact on the speed of delivery not
to do that I think would have been
unfair on the council in suggesting that
we could do it faster than we were able
and where we can we will of course do
that this is not giving people more time
to do little this is really recognizing
the challenges that we know are going to
come into the process but we will
endeavour as always to bring that down
wherever possible
page 20 performance monitoring and
reporting arrangements there was a
discussion at overview and scrutiny
committee about whether some of the
monitoring and reporting could be done
by said committee in the next council
and that was the only comment I wish to
make thank you okay any other comments
I'm not picking your points of cancer I
think it's we review these things and
perhaps you should be more aspirational
on some of the targets as well that
we're looking at so I'm open to comments
and looking at those sort of things so
yes I'll be part of my my review my
all-singing all-dancing thank you okay
members then the before you then the
recommendation is for recommendations to
approve the corporate strategy plan
action plan year five 2019 2020 Penix
one to prove the KPIs and targets
appendix 2 to prove the district health
measures appendix three and to prove the
monitoring arrangement set out in
paragraph three all those in favor thank
you
the next item on the end that gender is
the member development working forward
plant counselor well thank you chairman
this particular working group met on the
11th of February 2019 and even though it
did make this small adjustment to the
member members induction program six
months review with recommendation and
further offices being present the reason
for the report to come to you today is
we ask you that you look at the member
development working group forward Playa
Knight and unapproved
thank you before we move on to that I
just like to say that we just recently
come through a peer review process in
March and it was a very very positive
outcome from the from the the team that
came in here some of which were here two
years ago and they have seen
improvements and they commented such but
one thing I just like to say is that on
the member development where they
actually say that is class-leading so
you are doing exceptionally well in that
area so well done to Steven and David
and the team for doing that well done
okay write the recommendation ills any
other comments members no ok the
recommendation is that the member
development working forward group for
Planet items be approved all those in
favor
thank you the next item on the agenda is
development requirements supplementary
planning document adoption of Part II in
counselor pemberton would you like to
introduce this thank you as members of
cabinet will be aware we'll be bringing
forward supplementary planning documents
on a library and ongoing basis and this
is the latest part of the SPD to be
brought forward which is Part II that
refers to architectural style
construction and materials the policy
has been reviewed by officers have been
through a public consultation during
and April and further advice updates
have been put together so this has is
following on from ten other parts of the
SPD already brought to cabinet and
formally adopted so happy to take
questions through the relevant officer
who's an expert in this stuff at the
back if needs be but no you're not
you're not an expert Rob nuts seeking
support for the recommendation that the
council formerly adopts party
agricultural star construction and
materials as part of the development
requirements supplementary planning
document any comments members can take
it off I think this is an excellent team
who's who's brought it forward I know
one thing that I'd like to be assured is
that where we have stars identified
there has been a case in the past where
we've had the right style in the wrong
place and we had haunting stone
buildings in an era nobody know what the
stone building it's life before that was
a military pre-construction today's
would think a little bit wild and out of
control not any fault of members of
officers here but can we be assured that
there will be an area of focus that we
ensure that the stars identified so
clearly can be identified can be
allocated to the right patch and the
second question is how can we ensure
that developers actually follow these
styles rather than going to their
database of you know but we need three
three one day twenty eight to bed and
fifty eight three bed houses let's just
taken up our database how can we ensure
that these stars will actually be used
in reflecting the new houses are going
to come through so I think the very
first thing to say other than the
observation about the the chairman
talking about style
I think the very first thing to note
that is to say that it is heartening to
hear the chairman and I think the
Chairman's positive comments about the
work done here by officers is really
heartening and actually says more than I
can say about the great piece of work
that they've done once the the policy
has been adopted it enables our
development officers to be far more
robust around the use where appropriate
of various architectural styles and
materials I'll make no comment as to
whether there was a place for Horton
stone in anywhere other than Horton
[Laughter]
however I think the other the other so
I'm quite happy to give all of those
assurances that the chairman and of the
members are seeking well that comes with
a plea that across this Authority ward
members do actively engage both with our
planning officers their local
neighborhoods through neighborhood
groups and their and their planning
processes planning officers and the
developers at an early stage in relation
to development to ensure that they are
also making the case for the most
appropriate materials rather than here's
one I prepared earlier
thank you can see only the comments
organ being picky here on page 522 the
three illustrations the top worn on
don't believe you
23 is a double pitch canopy as always
officers ensure that there is something
put in there to ensure that the purpose
I read thoroughly by all members good
answer councillor Graham doesn't think
it any other comments okay I just like
to echo the Chairman's viewing on this I
think is very good document I didn't I
didn't
and again we're seeing some excellent
work coming out of the planning policy
department to the mode so well done and
keep me keep it up okay members the
recommendation before you is that the
Council formally adopts Part II like its
architectural style construction and
materials in closed brackets as part of
the development requirements of the
monetary planning document all those in
favor oh great thank you
excellent the next item on the agenda is
Thank You members bring forward the
great Wolford village design statements
and you will note the recommendations
that the great Warford village design
statement of 2019 be adopted as a local
information source to offer advice to
the relevant services of the district
council and that in relation to land
within the parish of great wharf that it
be endorsed as a material consideration
in determining planning applications in
accordance with the core strategy with
particular reference to policy cs9
design and distinctiveness that subject
to 1 & 2 above a request be made to
great Walford parish council rather than
to make arrangements for the document to
be made available to the public
village design statements are an
important piece of work to help set a
clear outline of the character of
particular village against which
planning applications should be assessed
I'd like to thank the group of
volunteers and great Wolford parish
council who have worked alongside our
officers to produce this piece of work
which is a really useful and important
piece of material guidance so with that
sort of vote of thanks for those who
have put this all together because none
of these things are easy and they do
take an awful lot of time and due
diligence by volunteers the VDS was
endorsed by a great Walters parish
council on the 26th of January this year
by letter to to us here at the district
council so subject to any questions or
any areas of nitpicking happy for us to
move to the happy to hope that you will
agree the recommendation Thank You
members our only comment No okay we'll
go to the recommendations then one that
the great Wofford videus 2019 appendix
to be adopted as a local information
source to offer advice to the relevant
services of stratford-on-avon district
council but the great Warford V DS 2019
as pertaining to land within the parity
break Walford be endorsed as a material
consideration in the determination of
planning applications in accordance with
a core strategy in particular policy cs9
design and distinctiveness and finally
not subject to one and two above a
request being made to great Walford
parish council for them to make
arrangements for the document to be made
available to the public all those in
favor
read thank you the next item is capital
budget monitoring council organ thank
you this report covers the first ten
months of the 2018 19 up to the 31st of
January 19 the total capital budget for
the year is six million five hundred and
forty three eight to seven and progress
on the capital projects is detailed in
Appendix one with appendix two covering
the section 106 funds thank you the
recommendation is to receive the
position on capital expenditure
thank you for customers just a couple of
quick cruise about section 106 money
page 133 fourth item from the bottom I
see that the money here sixteen thousand
had to be spent by January 2019 I wonder
since that date has now passed whether
we have to repay that money to the
Chanin's and also on page 130 120
thousand pounds for public art at the
Waitrose roundabout expires in June
seems to be getting perilously close to
the date and could we have some
reassurance on both those allergens
chairman thank you
Thank You chairman councilor Morse will
be pleased to know that both of those
items I have already taken up the public
art on the White Rose Island is one that
I have been seeking comfort on for
probably 12 months now knowing that
there are roadworks that have to take
place before that can actually happen
but I am reassured by the officers that
that that will be okay with regard to
the social housing monies this is a
little bit more complicated in lots of
monies go into the pots and Lots flow
out into different schemes but again I
am reassured that that is not in a
situation that is likely to result in it
being returned and I'm extremely
sensitive on this as we recall the
situation that happened some years ago
with regard to some section 106 monies
for a project in Sanborn thank you are
there any other questions okay then the
recommendation is that the position on
capital expenditure income for period
one to ten of 2018-19 is received and
any issues identified for further
consideration by a further report to the
cabinet or by the portfolio holder all
those in favor thank you right the next
item
is revenue budget monitoring cancer
organ Thank You chairman this report
covers the same period as the capital
budget monitoring and it analyzes
expenditure against profile budget
members will report call that earlier in
this year a number of initiatives were
added into this year's budget and it was
not anticipated that all of these would
be undertaken within this financial year
so this report includes the slippage
requests to cover these items and the
recommendations are on page 135 and the
result of these recommendations is a
forecast out turn favorable variance of
204 783 thank you cosmos one very quick
question chairman which I think has been
covered before but just because it
affects the subsequent item on page 159
investment income favorable variance of
45,000 that's after 10 months expected
outcome after 12 months of favorable
variance of 147,000 chairman could ask
is this because we're not accruing
income as we go along let me do the
period accounts we were doing that on
the cash basis and on the false basis so
we are expecting that payment at the
year-end any other questions okay well
good for the recommendation that the
variance has set that period 10 an
estimated revenue out term for 2018-19
is received and any issues identified
further consideration by a further
report to the cabinet by the poll by the
portfolio holder that the write-off be
identified within sorry the write-off
identified within section 2 to be noted
the revenue slippage identified within
section 33 to be approved or amended
sorry
yes okay all those in favor thank you
the next item then is our item 11 which
is well form outfield Airport airfield
compulsory acquisition of third-party
interest members are like to remind you
that we have blue papers on this so if
there is any discussion on this item
then we would need to go into closed
session due to the legal stroke
professional privilege of the financial
affairs relating to the authority so do
members want to go into closed session
guidance because you say if there's any
discussion on this surely if we should
only be not discussing if it's relates
to an item on the blue papers if it
relates to an item on the white papers
okay no no you're right I said if
anything on the blue papers that is
discussed if we want to discuss anything
on there then we would have to go into
closed session otherwise okay Council
organ do you want to thank you the
airfield
owners intention is to develop the
airfield for approximately 1800 new
dwellings and it is apparent from the
owners actions that they are seeking to
run down the current use of the airfield
site to pave the way for its closure and
redevelopment
although officers have commenced
negotiations with the owners powers of
compulsory purchase will be necessary to
properly protect the airfield site
government policy states that planning
policies should recognize the importance
of maintaining a national network of
general aviation airfields and the
council's core strategy supports the
retention of the airfield it is
considered that there are sufficient
compelling reasons as outlined within
the report for compulsory purchase
powers to be sought
this time the council has a clear idea
of how it intends to use the land and is
in discussions with potential operators
should the acquisition of the site be
successful the recommendations and
conclusions are in paragraph 9 which is
on page 160 and I would like to amend
paragraph 9 1 1 by adding on the words
after safeguard the existing use of the
order land alongside negotiations for
voluntary acquisition these words are in
order that it is quite clear that any
compulsory purchase would only be used
as and when the implications of any
compulsory purchase are clearly set out
in Paris 7 of the report and the risk
assessment is included in Para 8 the
necessary recommendations to make
confirm and implement a compulsory
purchase order to acquire wells boremont
field airfield are in paragraph 9 as
amended and the recommendation is that
these recommendations as amended are not
endorsed but approved thank you thank
you members are there any discussions
Kosmos Jim there are four points I would
like to raise do you wish me to German
we state that paragraph 1.6
although officers have started to enter
into negotiations with the owners to
secure the voluntary accusation that
position of the land German we've all
had invested
the landowners 86 the March only a few
days ago and it says in there the
council has made no attempt since
November 2016 to discuss their proposals
with us
so chairman our report is saying we've
had discussions this is saying there's
been nothing since 2008 16 they cannot
both be right Chinon just want to get
some clarification from our legal
officer here I'm aware as all members of
the cabinet are that we've had a pre
action protocol letter and that these
kind of conversations about who said
what and who did what start then to go
to the heart of the process and the
litigation here so I'm not entirely
comfortable that we should be going down
that road at all at this point without
some advice from officers on that thank
you so you'll be aware that we've got
two bits of paper that have been handed
round during the course of the meeting I
don't know whether you've had chance to
to look at them right so I'm first of
all I'm not I'm not aware that there's
any pre action protocol letter or what I
am aware of is that the letter to all
members from two of the littler family
dated the 6th of March which sets out a
number of points which have then been
responded to in the separate paper which
is headed well small F of update cabinet
report at the 11th of March I think that
you'll find within the response that
that particular point has been dispelled
to a certain extent but I will leave
perhaps other offices in the room to
give the detail around that apologies if
I've misunderstood where we currently
are at with that so
like take you take you on there sorry
so are we happy with that particular
point I think if people haven't had the
chance to read the update sheep jizz
under Sun which we know circulated
during the meeting we have made attempts
to open discussions with the owners of
Wells one airfield we don't really
recognize the tone of letter that they
sent to us they've not been terribly
obliging in their response we set out
small detail in the in the update sheet
to cabinet if what they're suggesting in
their letter is true we may be having
more productive discussions with them in
the near future
which would be along the spirit of the
twin tracking approach which councillor
organist it in the report
clarification could we just clarify that
this has no impact upon Wells bull
market I've found it difficult to work
out from the papers we've seen so far
whether the Wells bull market is
included in the air field site that
we're looking at yes well spawn airfield
we're still sort of getting to the
bottom of how all these structures work
well the sight of whales Bonaire field
is certainly with falls within the land
that we are seeking to acquire either
through voluntary additional poultry
purchase there is some form of agreement
between the market operators and the
airfield owners that we're working on
investigating at the moment so yes that
site is included the third point is on
the legal costs that we've set aside
1.125 billion for in next year's budget
as I've pointed out previously chairman
this is one pound in every seven that
we're trying to raise in council tax
next year we've just heard from mr.
Buckland on an earlier item that we're
only accruing when invoices are received
that's my interest we only do that on
cash account basis with all the
commitments otherwise as shown
Thank You Gemma for that clarification
so clearly members will be appraised on
a monthly basis of money that is being
spent
I'm sure members wouldn't want to get a
sudden nasty shock after six months to
find that all 1.1 million had been spent
without their realizing how it was
progressing so on that reassurance Thank
You chairman my final point is on page
156 when we talk about 4.1 one as a
result of these discussions a shortlist
potential partners has been drawn up
Sherman
perhaps the process of this could be
explained to me because are we saying
anybody else is excluded or are we going
out to a tender process this very much
gives the implication that it's a done
deal it's a slightly iterative process
to be honest we have to show to secure a
compulsory purchase order that we have a
compelling case in the public interest
and the ability to proceed and implement
the order so in surprise we needed to
demonstrate that we needed to engage
with people who could potentially run
the air-filled if and when that comes to
pass we would run a we would invite
expressions of interest widely we would
have a formal appraisal process and the
most viable bid against a set of agreed
criteria would be appointed as a partner
to join with us in it but at the moment
we have it's really people who have
approached us we've sought due diligence
to show that it is procedural but before
we settle on a final part that we would
do further investigations and by our
interest that's fine it's always going
to be an open process I won't ask where
the EU tender rules will apply that day
but but that's helpful helpful guidance
Chairman thank you thank you
I did just say also that on that
particular point talking about the 1.1 2
million person but in the citizens
panel feedback we got 61% two people
were in favor of that they were
supportive of for that so I think that
there's a certain groundswell of support
for this action thank you
are there any other questions that you
would like to ask okay then then I'm
going to go to the recommendations to
and conclusion now accounts are all
going to be just we go over what your
addition was to 9-1-1 please certainly
to add on to para 9-1-1 after the words
existing use of the order land alongside
negotiations for voluntary acquisition
and on the recommendation on page one
five one to alter the final word of the
recommendation which is shown as
endorsed to change it to approved
chairman I'm just wondering whether we
need to put out set hours in section
nine as amended
Thank You members the recommendation
before you is that the recommendations
set out in section 9 as amended as we've
just discussed are approved all those in
favor thank you
thank you very much and I'll move on now
to item 12 which is oh yes an active
fact in this particular point I think we
have an exemption request is that
correct are we asking personally film I
think the situation chairman is that
there are some blue papers at the back
of your packs which include the appendix
which is the business continuity
management policy and the proposal there
although it's for your decision is to
exempt that from publication so that if
there is any discussion about the blue
pet the blue paper then you'd be invited
to make a resolution to exclude the
press and the public thank you
right council house would you like to
introduce the item and just remind
members if you wish to discuss anything
in the blue paper we won't have to go
into closed session thank you very much
chairman yes
item 12 the business continuity
management policy just by way of
introduction or that confirmed the
Stratford District Council has a
statutory duty under the civil
contingency act 2004 to maintain
adequate plans in the case of a serious
incident to continue to function in an
operational state clearly these lands
are highly sensitive and it is for that
reason that the business management
policies are on blue paper and csw
retain intellectual property rights over
this dr. business continuity is vital so
that in the event of a serious incident
or natural disaster the business can
recover to an operational state in a
shorter time as possible there are three
elements to business Condon continuity
one is resilience this means that the
infrastructure is designed to cope with
most disruptions to the second one is
recovery this is to restore critical
business to functions as soon as
possible
and item 3 contingency this means that
the organization have the capability and
is ready to deal with any emergency what
the County Council's internal audit
service of carried out for review and
reports that our controls provide
substantial assurance that risks are
being managed following the report SDC
have engaged with Coventry survival of
Warwickshire emergency planning and
business continuity team to provide a
dedicated expert resource for us we have
Interjet dial with us from the
organisation is here today and he is
prepared to answer any questions that
you might have
David Platts and our senior management
team are responsible for ensuring that
this policy is fit for purpose and have
already done a considerable amount of
work but there is still some work to do
with individual service teams to be
employed and this is ongoing business
continuity has to work right across the
organisation and this policy enables it
to happen the recommendation is that
cabinet approved the business continuity
management plan Thank You cancer are
there any questions either cancer House
or ended yet I think you got away with
up
[Laughter]
okay members the recommendation before
you is that business continuity
management policies approved and adopted
all those in favor
thank you right members the next items
are on block we are looking at item 13
the cabinet work program to father or
just read it out thank you very much
okay the next item okay thank you very
much indeed Carolina key decision three
development requirements SPD two to
endorse further parts of the development
recall it's SPD for adoption of the
council which are Part C accessing
connectivity Part D buildings and layout
Part F residential amenity part s
general and local needs housing and
party specialized housing okay so that's
that particular item thank you
you've seen the 3sat ejek policy
Advisory Group they receive the minutes
for that member development working
group for that those in block items
agreed thank you
item urgent business any business no no
no urgent business therefore I think we
can close the meeting thank you very
much indeed